la gráfica de ye igual al valor absoluto
de x se refleja respecto al eje x y
después de escala verticalmente en un
factor de 7 cual es la ecuación de la
nueva gráfica pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolverlo muy bien trabajemos esto
juntos
probablemente no necesites dibujarlo
pero lo haré para que todos podamos ver
lo que está pasando digamos que este es
mi eje x y este es mi eje y
y es igual al valor absoluto de x así
que para los valores positivos de x que
va a ser igual a x el valor absoluto de
cero es cero el valor absoluto de uno es
uno el valor absoluto de dos es 2 de
modo que lo vamos a ver así va a tener
una pendiente igual a 1 y luego para los
valores negativos cuando tomas el valor
absoluto vas a tomar el opuesto vas a
obtener el valor positivo de modo que se
va a ver así déjenme ver si puedo
dibujar esto un poco más claro este es
un dibujo a mano así que tengan
paciencia pero espero que esto les
resulte familiar ya han visto la gráfica
de jay es igual al valor absoluto de x
con anterioridad ahora vamos a pensar en
las diferentes transformaciones en
primer lugar nos dicen que se refleja
respecto al eje x por ejemplo si tengo
un valor de x justo aquí antes tomaría
el valor absoluto de x y tendría este
resultado pero ahora queremos reflejarlo
respecto al eje x así que esencialmente
queremos tomar el negativo de ese valor
con el valor de x correspondiente por
ejemplo en esta x antes tomaríamos el
valor absoluto de x pero ahora queremos
reflejarlo respecto al eje x y queremos
el valor negativo en general lo que
estamos haciendo es obtener el negativo
del valor absoluto de x si quieren
reflejar respecto al eje x debes obtener
el valor negativo estás escalando la
expresión o la función a un negativo así
que esto va a ser que es igual a menos
el valor absoluto de x una vez más
cualquiera que sea el valor absoluto de
x que te dan para una x dada ahora
queremos obtener su valor negativo ahora
queremos su valor negativo esto es
reflejar respecto al eje x pero luego
nos dicen que debemos escalar en un
factor de 7 y la manera en que entiendo
esto es que si estás escalando
verticalmente en un factor de 7
cualquiera que sea el valor de ye que
obtienes para una equis dada ahora
quieres obtener 7 veces el valor de g
para una equis dada
y si pensamos en esto algebraica mente
bueno si quiero obtener siete veces el
valor de iu tendría que multiplicar esto
por siete por lo que obtendría que es
igual a menos siete por el valor
absoluto de x y esto es esencialmente lo
que nos están pidiendo cuál es la
ecuación de la nueva gráfica de modo que
esta sería el negativo hace que se
refleje respecto al eje x y luego el 7
la escala verticalmente en un factor de
7 pero solo para entender cómo se vería
bueno multiplica 0 por 7 eso no cambia
nada pero cualquiera que sea está x aquí
era menos x pero ahora vamos a obtener
menos 7x así que veamos 2 3 4 5 6 7 lo
pondría por aquí entonces nuestra
gráfica ahora se vería así se va a
estirar a lo largo del eje vertical si
estuviéramos escalando verticalmente en
un factor que tuviera un valor absoluto
menor que 1 entonces eso haría que la
gráfica fuera más ancha
voy a hacer que se vea un poco más
simétrica se va a ver así pero el
problema clave y la razón por la que
estoy dibujando esto es para que veas
que parece que se está escalando
verticalmente se está estirando en la
dirección vertical por un factor de 7 y
la manera en que hacemos esto de forma
algebraica es multiplicar por 7 y el
negativo es lo que lo refleja respecto
al eje x hasta el próximo vídeo